tel nouveau casse tête ça fait un petit
moment qu'on n'avait pas fait un sur la
chaîne on a trouvé un truc très stylée
je pense déjà à comprendre comment ils
fonctionnent mais il paraît bien relou
affaire il a un petit nom il s'appelle
le cigare de churchill je vous mettrai
le lien dans la description si jamais
vous voulez vous procurer suis là où un
autre exemplaire parce que je sais pas
quelle est l'officiel en fait de ça
c'est un qui est reproduite dans pas mal
de boutiques mais il est très cool
bon alors c'est parti on a quoi on a un
truc long et dur juste ici titre des
fois je m'adresse derrière parce que
loïc il est caché derrière derrière la
caméra on a également un boulon enfin et
croates [ __ ] ça va recommencer cette
histoire l'histoire terrible de l'écrou
du boulon et de la vis extrême d'un
écrou un bon je sais jamais lequel est
lequel ils écroulent 12,7
oui ça c'est le boulon saas et les
régions ça c'est le boulon et salé kron
tout faux le boulon et l'encens et
boulons ses envies ses chronos du passif
au pour ses pas dans tout ça dans la
région d'avancé face à des grosses et
madames des chasseurs
non c'est donc en tout cas il y a la
rondelle je sais pas je voulais dire
dans les commentaires que j'y connais
rien c'est vrai j'ai pas vulgarisateur
bricolage apparemment il ya la tige est
tordue il ya la bouboule ya le truc
qu'on est dur
tout ça est dans une flasque envers
c'est du solide ça monsieur
donc mon but c'est de le défaire et
après de le refaire pour moi l'idée
c'est que comme la tige là on peut rien
en faire pour l'instant pour l'instant
il faut dévisser et je pense qu'il
ferait des lycées avec la bille qui va
frotter comme ça sur le bouton mais
qu'est ce qu'on voit on voit qu créant
tout cela dit [ __ ] ça commence
ça fait bouger le boulon en entier donc
c'est pas très intéressant comment on
attend si je veux vie c'est quelque
chose je fais ça si je veux des suisses
et cheville donc il faudrait que je
mette la bbc la coince ici est-ce que
cela même taille à sous qui tourne
jusqu'alors le prélat ces délices ou pal
à temps oui c'est ça davis
est ce que je fais quelque chose là non
là ça fait dans le sens des aiguilles
d'une montre j'ai dit il faut que ça
passe comme ça [ __ ] oui donc s'est
inversée donc à temps ouais j'ai trouvé
un casse-tête en fait il est stylé mais
je crois qu'il est simple sa mère elle
est simple tu va le garder ou pas le
seul mais le simple oui c'est celui de
bloquer l'abîmé il faut que tous pas que
ça tourne en eau en fait faut pas
s'attendre quand bas ou là j'ai bougé un
peu là tu pourras couper le passage le
dis j'ai dit que j'allais leur faire à
la fin non mais bougez pas toi oh là
qu'est ce que tu fais là il ya
s'agrandit ou pas les jeux l'un plus ou
pas parce que j'ai à dire je peux pas
essayer de le trancher puisque tu
reviens je peux pas tourner à cause de
la tige est en faire et peut-être après
quand je quand je leur ai un truc débit
sais pas peut-être puissance par le bas
oh c'est pas mal ça au heat ya quelque
chose le fatah j'ai l'impression que ça
bouge pas trop en haut alors que
j'arrive à faire bien bougé en bas là
bah oui là on a une progression on a
hélas du coup ces sept chiffres
enfin cette île ça prend à peu près un
milliard d'années mais sinon est ce que
tu cherches il vraiment 2010 et d'un
port pas compliquer mes cigares j'ai
trouvé une technique
alors forcément si tu as envie de le
fumer bon c'est pas très rapidement on
passe à une bonne manière d'arrêter de
fumer tue range tes petits gars étaient
club comme ça dans les petites
bouteilles parce qu'après ça doit
tellement énervé que tu as vraiment
envie de fumer je pense qu'on a bientôt
fini la première étape
après c'est la tige en clair qu'il fait
peur je vois pas trop comment le sortir
même le bouillon d'ailleurs dit moi a
expliqué moi les histoires de bougon de
trucs une bonne fois pour toutes que je
comprenne qui t'appelle comment aller
de tourner sur la bille mon bel ami
parce que des clubs immenses lève ce qui
se passe c'est que après il est debout
alors même si il se lève en vrai il
tourne quoi ces rouleaux avec moi plus
grand chose là peut-être j'aurais dû le
faire sans la bouteille je t'en penses
logique non après ça faisait une vidéo
ça faisait un petit top quoi oui j'ai un
compte dictats que je sais pas si vous
savez j'ai un compte tictoc vous mais
quand même dans la description je fais
autre chose c'est cesser les différents
mais c'est pas inintéressant attention
tik tok voici enfin la solution pour
faire croire que vous avez quatre doigts
alors qu'en fait vous en avez bien 5
c'est extrêmement simple il suffit de
cash et l'index derrière le pis comme ça
vous le cacher bien vous le temps manqué
un petit peu et ensuite vous pouvez
plier les doigts comme ça c'est comme ça
qu'on voit et après sur cet angle de vue
vous avez peut-être doigts j'ai vu des
diots où les gens ont les doigts comme
ça c'est pas bon il faut vraiment que
les doigts il soit bien comme ça on peut
même un peu les ouvrir et c
et voilà le secret était pas plus
compliqué que ça allait bien
oui ok j'ai tué le casse-tête fin de
vidéo avec générique c'est de là que je
crois qu'elle a été fait cette femme une
fois oui ok mais comment je vais faire
pour tout remettre tout à l'heure je ne
suis pas encore là mais bon alors toi
quand tu enlèves la west ham à berges de
la part la console peut le tourner non
pas d'un coût de la pâte en passant je
repère aussi comment elle est mise je
regarde un peu comment c'est fait pour
tout à l'heure quand je devrais de rom
est bien le maître en fait faut qu'ils
rentrent par là moi je pense que ça se
fasse tripes par le haut par le coup
d'oeil si j'arrivais à bien faire
descendre le coût de la savait trop doux
en fait que si j'arrive elle tournait
c'est lui qui soit ne peut pas tourner
là dedans il a pas assez d'espacé pour
tourner si lui l'a dit jean fer
j'arrivais à la halle à faire pointer de
leur côté là je serais tellement que je
pense mais je crois qu'il ya eu 8 joli
joli chauffage sais pas comment j'ai
fait ça mais c'était pas si mal
moi je pense que comme ça je peux la non
[ __ ] c'était dans ma tête force est
pris pour cible de retourner ok je vais
leur mettre dans sa position d'origine
petit changement dans le décor on avait
oublié de finaliser le décor casse tête
par donc deux doses d'iodé
moi je toujours sur la tige et pourquoi
ils tombent pas est ce qu'il faudrait
pas qu'il soit retourné ben non ça non
plus tiens les rentrées cette tige un
jour tu es forcément qu'elle voulait
sortir une autre un autre jour je ne
sais pas si bête que dix ans vrai quand
je la regarde comme ça que ça pourrait
passer mais comment comment non là ça
tombe pas tout seul naturellement passé
la bureautique pour juillet un petit peu
le pourquoi comment quant aux le roulé
dessus vous avez vu il ya la bielle a
roulé dessus et ça s'est enfoncé un peu
plus que tout à l'heure où je sais pas
si c'est une impression pas mais ça me
rappelle les gens là vous savez qu'ils
construisent des bateaux dans les
bouteilles c'est complètement husa
prélève les voilà la fin là le hic est
en train de vous faire voir il existe
d'autres trucs comme ça dans les
bouteilles mais un peu plus six ans une
illusion alors il ya des fruits dans les
bouteilles
donc là clairement il fonce et le fruit
dans la bouteille vous mettre sur
l'arbre est aussi un mec qui fait des
jeux de cartes dans des bouteilles
regarder et ça c'était l'objet de
collection je sais même pas comment est
construit ça j'ai l'impression de faire
ma pub c'est à dire que naturellement on
a envie de forcer dans ce sens là et
plus ça va plus je me dis que c'est
vraiment pas une bonne idée puisque tu
as me vient pas du tout
[Musique]
bien naturellement il de e-loue que ça
je tourne c'est tout à l'heure quand
même s'était enfoncé un peu plus que ça
ça va appuyer avec ça à temps et si je
mets la bille est ce que je peux appuyer
alors ça me retourne plus qu'autre chose
jamais pourtant ça ça devrait passer en
vrai je me demande s'il est bien
raisonnable ce truc moi désolé vous
voyez pas mais sachez que moi j'y crois
oui non si oui si c'est bon ben on n'a
pas tout compris on a pas mais c'est
passé ok ah merde [ __ ] j'ai pas repéré
je vois comment s'est fait parce que ben
on va passer à l'étape où va falloir
leur offert site déjà sans être dans la
fiole je sais pas le faire
oui c'est comme ça que je les sorties
non quand je vais tour m il faut que
j'arrive à faire un truc comme ça
est-ce qu'il peut arrêter de faire cette
espèce de cuillères soul bon ok il
faudra que j'arrive à le re rentrer
comme ça la bille l'écrou leblond la
tige 20 balles et le sig a et la b voir
il va leur faire trop j'ai commencé par
essayer de remettre 7 6 en dessous
satan mais non mais attends j'ai déjà
perdu tous mes repères j'ai dit qu'il
fallait qu'elle rentre par là par là
comme ça pour ensuite faire ça ça va
être tellement hard de l'euro rend
triste record on peut faire aimer c'est
à temps mais je suis bête pour leur
faire je peux refaire les mêmes actions
que quand je les des faits on est
d'accord avec ça loïc et quand je les
des faits on en était là en fait il est
sorti à un peu genre comme ça donc je
peux le faire comme ça et je suis bête
si je me donne des difficultés qui avait
pas là maintenant il faut que je fasse
rentrer ok du coup pour le rentrer je
vais forcément avoir besoin de
l'habillement où je penche pour le
pousser et bien qu'ils viennent avait il
y en a gardé la bille hockey aux
dommages qui avait pas le trou parce que
s'il y avait le trou c'est con il aurait
dû faire le trou plus loin alors tu sais
le truc en faire j'ai jamais réussi à
enlever de thaler quasiment là il part
quitte lentement
mais ce qui marche pas c'est que là
c'était pas qu'on mon idée mais s'y
rendent par le bas c'était plus la
config de départ la config de départ il
était comme ça par rapport à ça qui
faisait la cuillère et sage sûr que ça
va m'aider de thaler je pense que c'est
petit ça m'aide pense qu'il faut le
passer par le haut mais vous voulez pas
vous barrez nous tous là voilà est-ce
que ici
en attendant là il ya une belle
ouverture tu vois ou pas
robin faut que tu vois la ga geler la la
ça fait rentrer tout on va faire pour
donner les premiers coups de vice parce
qu'en fait quand il va falloir leur
tournée après parce que la dc c'est pas
possible un os est peut-être là que la
cuillère elle sert à quelque chose
ce temps pour visser c'est dans le sens
des aiguilles
[Musique]
lire
anna n'était pas le luxe est sorti
l'accessoire ultime
vous savez ce que c'est c'est béthune
est en fait il ya toujours un élément
dont on n'a pas besoin qui vient qui se
croit trop un peu chez lui quoi et ça si
j'arrivais faire des coups à droite
[Musique]
je l'aimais il l'est il est lié à un
poil de tu vois ok je crois qu'il est
c'est curieux du coup maintenant
faudrait qu'il soit comme ça
que je donne des trucs comme ça
est-ce que lui là il faut qu'il reste
enfoncée ici s'il n'est pas enfoncé la
tourner en même temps tâche est en train
de me faire mon fort boyard puisqu'ils
veulent comme un vide pas mais les
comptes de fort boyard pour rien jours
ceci n'est pas une blague c'est vrai
quoi je viens de la rochelle mon
régisseur lumière travail sur le fort
j'ai vécu toute ma vie en fait à côté du
phare et s'il ment jamais indiqué je
comprends pas pourquoi j'adore réfère le
fort vous pouvez les harceler pour leur
faire voir qu'il ya du monde derrière
surtout leur réseau je vous autorise à
l'espagne pour la prochaine saison
[ __ ] j'ai j'ai vu que j'étais
olalalala j'ai dévissé deux fois là
c'est pas mal c'est ce qui bloque la
bille et le bloc sur le petit truc en
faire après ben voilà comme quoi il faut
pas quand on a les mains moites faut pas
hésiter t'as vu comment ça va tout seul
moi trop trop juste
[Musique]
oui quand même que je suis plus serré
qu'au départ peut plus arrêter valdi oui
franchement j'ai des tas ou par cast est
rondement menée je suis très satisfait
d'avoir fait ce casse tête il était très
agréable à faire je vous fait gagner sur
instagram sur le post qui est juste ici
vous allez lire dans la description vous
avez également le lien pour l'acheter
la tournée du spectacle reprend c'est
l'ultime tournée de ce spectacle parce
qu après j'arrête spectacle complètement
donc si vous voulez voir vous allez bien
dans la description mais sûrement
quelques vide autour de moi il compris
le fameux zénith de paris
il reste encore quelques places vous
avez sûrement le plan qui vient
d'apparaître
merci d'avoir regardé la vidéo penser à
la ligue et si vous avez regardé c'est
jusqu'au bout s'il vous plaît
abonnez-vous aux petits mais la cloche
pour pas rater des prochaines c'est
dommage vous les voyez en retard ici je
vous mets un casse tête que j'aime faire
avec loïc assez récemment
et ici un petit bout d'excalibur parce
que ça fait plaisir
à très bientôt chat